our life is good in Germany the economy
is humming the summer is returned and
Frankfurt is celebrating Italy week
Pizza olive bread suckling pig the Dolce
Vita European Central Bank President
Mario Draghi hasn't been cited but some
people like Ovid Hiva would like to have
a few words with him the capital market
expert from Nevada Bank is unhappy with
plans to cut the prime interest rate a
relaxed monetary policy creates the
wrong incentives if you tell the
countries in the south of the eurozone
go ahead go into debt at ultra-low
interest its pain free then there's no
more incentive to carry out reforms like
we carried out here in Germany years ago
with the agenda 2010 agenda 2010 was a
series of labor market reforms and deep
cuts in social benefits they made
Germany more competitive but back to the
present day the change means if a bank
wants to borrow a million euros from the
European Central Bank it will only have
to pay five hundred euros a year in
interest since last Thursday when the
new monetary measures were announced
jean-philippe liqueur financial
correspondent for the French newspaper
lazy coal has been busy twittering and
writing articles he knows what French
politicians want from the central bank
if a long does it be a demand that the
ECB do more to boost French business by
throwing more liquidity on the market or
by contributing to devalue in the euro
that would help a country like France to
export more Airbus aircraft for example
that sounds like economics 101 in their
first year at the Frankfurt School of
Finance and management students learned
that cheap money heats up an economy but
also poses a hazard
yes the first reaction of many people to
such low interest rates will be to shift
more of their investments to the stock
market or to real estate and since
everyone will have the same plan there's
the danger of a bubble vestido tiga
father Acevedo sounds like 2008 in the
banking metropolis of Frankfurt people
remember well how the American real
estate market pumped up with cheap money
became a bubble that then burst the
shockwaves plunged the whole world into
a financial crisis evarin the central
banks learned anything if the central
bank wants to rescue the system using
the same flawed measures by continuing
to pump up this bubble in the hope that
it won't burst how is that going to work
and if the bubble does burst the damage
will be so great not least culturally
and on the economic mood that the
collapse of Lehman Brothers in 2008 will
look like a kid's birthday party ah life
in Germany is good for now pizza is
still selling like hotcakes but not
everyone likes the taste of the ECB's
relaxed monetary policy